alors jacques ipaq les wapitis attaque
les trains tant que cette histoire
allait bien tout ça serait pas arrivé si
le chef de la section de regina hall
factory avait été informé des moeurs des
wapitis moins ils ne savaient pas l drap
il faut que je voulais frites bien tout
en détail le chemin de fer de regina a
hole factory au canada dans le nord du
canada dans l'état de manitoba traverse
une immense réserve où il ya des
milliers et des milliers ou dizaines de
billets de wapiti et le wapiti c'est un
grand cerf insert mais beaucoup beaucoup
plus grand que le no d'ailleurs vous le
voyez maintenant sur votre écran c'est
un très très grand cher qu'il ya un
mètre quarante au garrot depuis des bois
où je vais les bois du cerf qui tombe
chaque année au printemps et qui
repousse à l'automne des bois qui ont la
taille d'un homme mohamed 65 avec
l'andouille et de massacrer la partie
qui va aller de pointe qui viennent
comme ça tout droit dur comme des épées
ainsi dimanche superbe et au contraire
de notre serre qui est plutôt craintif
extrêmement agressif et d'une force
incroyable tous les les trappeurs de là
bas vous raconteront qu'ils ont vu parce
que c'est vrai d'ailleurs je n'ai pu en
europe et y attaquer par un loup le tuer
à coups de sabots tapant dessus caceres
à beaupuy fini on a même vu filmer un
wapiti qui se battait contre un ours
c'est quand même un morceau un ours
n'est pas le tuer avec ces andouilles et
de massacres c'est point tellement dur
n'est ce pas le perforer et le réduire
en bouillie à force de piétiner c'est
donc un animal une force herculéenne et
qui n'a peur absolument de rien à part
ça il est tout à fait comme nos serres
c'est à dire que chaque année à
l'automne en septembre ou octobre chez
eux
ils bram pour se constituer son harem de
bié sa petite compagnie de guiche et ce
bram diffère de celui de nos serres
l'onho c'est quand un drame très connu
en trois parties alors que le brame du
wapiti extrêmement puissant comment un
sport une note extrêmement grave et puis
monte monte monte jusqu'à devenir un
coup ci fait terriblement légumes qui
dure plusieurs minutes
monte-en-l'air à peamount affolant comme
boire et à ses brames sont des défis
quand un wapiti entend bras mais cette
espèce de hurlements qui commencera avec
défini près du 1 au 3 pieds tic il
comprend que l'autre le mets au défi ils
vont se battre j'ai pas de bataille pour
rire alors voilà ce qu avec le wapiti au
matin le chemin de fer le chemin de fer
donc traverse la grande réserve des
wapitis et jusqu'à présent il fallait le
gagner moi il était directeur maintenant
train vapeur ont été tirés par des
locomotives à vapeur et les mécaniciens
de locomotive devait siffler on leur
instruction il va siffler trois fois en
traversant le parc une fois en entrant
dans la réserve une fois au milieu de la
réserve une fois la fin de la réserve
d'un grand si flex de locomotive à
vapeur tout allait bien les wapitis
avait pris l'habitude du sifflet du
train vapeur mon dieu il sortait de la
ligne s'il était dessus et qu'autour est
vieux balai wapiti regarder passer le
train à vapeur comme nos vaches
regardent passer les trains quoi qu'il
en soit occupé puis là dessus on à
électrifier la ligne
va bien sauf que le premier train qui
traverse la grande réserve une fois
qu'ils arrivent à hall factory au
terminus le mécanicien descendre sa
locomotive absolument d'infos lui et
coup retrouvé le directeur de la ligne
angers-le affreux j'ai été attaqué par
un wapiti
il ya un grand mât aloi pythie qui a
chargé la locomotive il aimerait s'est
écrasé contre une locomotive de 30
tonnes lancé à 140 m eur mais au mois
piétinent ou ne fait pas le poids est
écrabouillé compteur le directeur didier
oui mais le second train qui est arrivé
le mécanicien sort aussi de sa motrice
électrique etc ou revoir le directeur
j'ai été attaqué par un wapiti ils sont
fous ces wapiti et pendant les huit
premiers jours d'exploitation de la lie
toutes les fois qu'un train arrivait le
mécanicien descendait l'islet j'ai été
attaqué par un wapiti et le wapiti s'est
écrasé votre bonne locomotive
pas comprendre ce que c'est bon appétit
qui supportaient les locomotives à
vapeur ne vous les prêtres traction
électrique et ce qui c'était contre les
décideurs c'était dingue pas plus que ça
se passe aux canadiens où les gens sont
défenseurs dé m beaucoup plus que chez
nous les
logistep protestait on assassine les
wapitis envoyer les jours nous en parler
c'est à ce qu il fallait qu'on y porte
romane
alors jour à force de tuer les wapitis
rond pourraient plus n'est-ce pas on a
demandé un zoologue ou un watt pitot
l'omc si vous voulez de monter sur la
locomotive pour voir ce qui se passait
dit mot sur un correctif traverse à 140
à l'heure la ligne actuellement il ya un
wapiti qui s'écrasera locomotive mais à
l'arrivée le zoologue avait compris
la sirène la locomotive électrique au
lieu d'être un coup de sifflet pointu
c'était une sirène qui émettait labora
sont très graves et qui ensuite monte
monte monte elle monte elle est devenue
un coup tu fais très aigu oui comme ça
qui ressemble au brame du wapiti et les
wapitis attendant le coup de sifflet
très grave qui devenait un coup de
sifflet réguler qui ressemblait alors
bram croyez que c'est un autre beattie
qui les défiaient kg dieye moi je passe
moi je suis là un super costaud que toi
et chargerait communaux peur de rien
alors évidemment on a changé la sirène
les locomotives électriques et les voies
petty n'attaque plus l'état est
maintenant touché rétablie dans le parc
des wapitis donc ouais faut comprendre
les choses venu tenir c'est joli